Plus quatre.
Et plus quatre.
Ah non !
Là il est mort.
Ah !
Il y a déjà un acheteur.
Allez, super.
Il ne reste plus qu'à emballer.
Merci !
Bonne journée.
Ah, je me suis enlevé une petite peau.
- Fais voir.
- Ouais, là, tu vois ?
Ah, mais il faut amputer là.
Quoi ?
Ah non !
- C'est un cancer du doigt.
- Non, non, attendez !
C'est un cancer du Covid même.
Non, c'est une petite peau.
On va couper à l'épaule.
Je viens de croiser à l'instant
le ministre de l'Économie dans les couloirs.
Il m'a demandé de toute urgence
d'organiser une réunion
afin de parler des
derniers chiffres du chômage.
Alors ? Cette anecdote
est-elle vraie
ou est-elle fausse ?
- Ah !
- Je sais pas.
OK, OK, vas-y.
- Attention !
- J'y vais.
C'est à toi.
Non, non !
Bah d'accord.
Peut-être là !
Allez, allez.
Et ben, je suis millionnaire.
Ah, mais c'est pas vrai !
Ils veulent faire passer une loi
où les utilisateurs devraient prouver
qu'ils ont plus de 18 ans.
Non, mais en plus on leur demande à
l'entrée du site quel âge ils ont.
Ça va !
Le patron, il ne va pas aimer.
D'ailleurs il arrive.
Bon alors, c'est quoi cette histoire ?
Moi, j'ai 47 ans.
La preuve, j'ai appuyé
sur « J'ai plus de 18 ans. »
Oui, bien merci ! Voilà !
On pensait à faire un Michou et de…
Oh non.
Ça y est, il a recommencé.
Il est lourd avec ça.
- Bouh !
- Ah mais putain !
Tu n'as que ça à foutre franchement ?
- Je vous ai eus, hein.
- Ça ne me fait plus rire !
- Ah ça va.
- Ce n'est plus marrant.
Faites gaffe à la cafèt j'ai planqué
plein de Thierry Lhermitte !
Comment il s'appelle le ministre ?
Elle ne veut pas dire, elle ne veut pas dire.
On dit que c'est faux.
C'est vrai !
J'ai reçu mes airpods d'AliExpress.
Ah, des vrais ?
Mais bien sûr.
Attention Didier a commandé sur Wish
la dernière fois un VTT
il était petit comme ça.
Ah !
Vas-y ! Mets-le dans l'oreille.
Essaie-le, essaie-le.
Paf, on enlève l'adaptateur secteur.
Mais comment ils font
pour charger leur téléphone ?
Ils se démerdent.
Je ne comprends pas bien la démarche.
Mais si c'est une démarche éco.
...logique ?
Nomique.
Ah !
Samsung enlève les chargeurs de leur boîte
pour faire croire que c'est écolo.
Ah, mais il faut qu'on
fasse exactement pareil.
On va même plus loin.
On enlève le téléphone.
Ah ça, c'est une démarche éco…
...nomique !
Bon allez, je vous laisse.
Je me casse, je dois
aller chercher mon ado.
Je me suis garé en double file.
Salut, les petits cons.
Sale galère.
Il fait plus jeune que 47.
J'aurais dit 42.
Bon concernant le bilan de fin d'année.
Pour le rayon chasse et pêche
et le rayon tennis de table,
il va falloir qu'on se mette d'accord
sur une stratégie.
Maintenant qu'on est séparés,
on peut se dévoiler nos identités.
OK, mais ça doit rester entre nous.
Évidemment.
Attends, mais depuis le début,
tu es Stéphane Plaza ?
Bien sûr. Et toi, tu es qui alors ?
Tu ne le sauras jamais.
Ah le bâtard !
Vous avez vu, on a remis le Monopoly.
J'adore.
Ah, j'ai gagné un McFlurry.
J'ai gagné une petite frite.
Ah non, j'ai rien.
Mais même ici !
Merde, on ne fait
que perdre des utilisateurs,
- ça n'a pas de sens.
- On pourrait mettre moins de pub aussi.
Ou vérifier les fake news.
On change de nom.
On s'appelle Meta.
Non, mais tu n'as pas bien compris
On crée un monde virtuel.
Mais tu n'as pas écouté parce que…
Avec un casque VR.
Mais tu n'as pas peur avec tes idées
On crée le metaverse.
On vend des trucs qui n'existent pas.
Allez, au travail.
La réunion est terminée.
- On replie ?
- Allez !
Non il faut tourner en fait.
C'est ça.
Ouais voilà, il faut faire un huit.
Attention, il y a encore les sardines.
Monsieur Zimmer, s'il vous plaît,
une dernière musique.
Je n'ai plus d'idées, j'arrête.
Allez, on bosse un peu
sur Dune encore un peu.
Non, j'ai dit non !
Mais c'est génial ça.
C'est exactement ce qu'on cherche.
Je vous envoie la facture.
Vous ne saurez jamais.
Hé pas mal le metaverse, en fait.
- J'aime bien.
- Mais oui, on est en réunion
tout en restant en slip chez nous.
J'adore.
- Elle est où Hélène ?
- Bah je ne sais pas.
Demandez pas ce qui se passe,
je ne peux pas le changer.
10 millions !
On l'a fait !
Excusez-moi !
C'est pour quelle association ?
C'est pour le…
Pour le cancer.
Contre le cancer !
Ou les pauvres.
Contre les pauvres. POUR les pauvres.
Ce court-circuit, c'est pas vrai.
Il faut absolument le réparer.
Thomas Pesquet !
Qu'est-ce qu'il fout ?
Je fais un TikTok.
Pourquoi on l'a pris lui déjà lui ?
Vous nous aviez promis une prime.
Ah oui, la prime.
Félindra, tête de tigre.
Les chiffres sont excellents cette année.
- C'est vrai !
- Bravo, Monsieur Bezos.
Oh non !
C'est Elon Musk qui est
devenu l'homme le plus riche.
Ce n'est plus moi le premier.
Ah non !
Mais regardez, vous avez quand même
200 milliards, Monsieur Bezos.
Mais c'est nul, 200 milliards.
C'est nul.
Et voilà je viens de lui passer devant
à l'autre tête d'œuf.
- Je suis le plus riche.
- Enfin Monsieur Musk,
Noël approchant, Amazon risque de prendre
un peu de valeur.
Et ben voilà ! Jeff Bezos est
repassé premier.
Ça va vite.
Mais non c'est moi qui doit être le premier !
Je veux une fusée !
Une fusée ?
Vous êtes l'homme
le plus riche du monde, Monsieur Bezos.
Et oui, Elon Musk est seulement deuxième
avec sa fusée désormais.
Avec sa fusée ?
Moi aussi, je veux une fusée !
Et même qu'on dirait
que moi, je vais être dedans.
Et bien félicitations.
Vous pouvez signer votre augmentation Didier.
Ah super !
Vas-y.
Allez-y.
Allez, Didier.
On signe juste là.
C'est juste là.
Ah non !
Didier !
Pardon, pardon, désolé.
Arrêtez !
Lâchez-moi !
Tu attends quelqu'un ?
Ah ben non.
Non !
Preums !
- Preums !
- Non !
Non, c'est moi en premier.
On dit que c'est moi !
C'était moi en premier.
- Regarde la ligne là.
- Non non non !
C'est moi !
Je n'en peux plus de son saxophone.
Je vais le lui faire
bouffer par le fion.
Clique juste ici pour voir le bêtisier
et les scènes coupées.
Allez, vas-y.
Tu cliques.
Bon, c'est assez bon pour…
J'ai mis un budget
de fou sur la prochaine série.
Ça va cartonner.
J'espère que c'est pas
encore l'adaptation live
d'un animé japonais parce que…